make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and i
just woke up a little bit ago so bear
with me here
but uh in light of the snyder cut of the
justice league coming out i figured we'd
make a video
explaining darkseid but here's the rub
right here was the difficulty in getting
this sorted out one
i kind of figured we could go back and
do it from like his first appearance
in well really the forever people number
one back in 1970
and while it is a possibility the
problem is so much happened between
then and now with the character of
darkseid it's not really feasible to
turn a person into an expert
on a character like that in 25 minutes
if we include
all that stuff the second thing is that
what we see in the dc cinematic universe
at the moment
is largely just based on the new 52 and
a ton of stuff has happened with dark
side
in the new 52 and so what i figured we'd
do is kind of break away from tradition
for this video
and focus on one single era at
darkseid's history which is basically
the new 52 right to give you
to kind of make you an expert on the
modern depiction of dark side in dc
comics which is probably all you really
care about if you are wanting to get
into the character anyway
especially considering if you've been
watching zack snyder's justice league
the current version of darkseid
originally appeared
in justice league volume 2 issue number
three back in 2011. there's a few things
you need to know here
the first is that the reason why it's
called justice league volume 2
is that while the team has been around
for an exceedingly long time
that the original justice league comic
book was basically axed during the
events of crisis on infinite earth a
story that was written back in the 1980s
that was designed to basically
reboot the entirety of dc comics kind of
you know wipe everything clean and start
over again and so when that happened
instead of getting justice league as we
had known it dc ended up creating what
was called
justice league international and that
was a whole new justice league concept
it wasn't until the new 52 and the
relaunch of dc comics so the reboot of
dc comics that we actually got a return
of the original justice league roster
you kind of got it with jla by grant
morrison back in the day but dc doesn't
really count that right they don't
really count that as the actual justice
league comic because at that point it
was
justice league of america it was a
different name right and so the
important thing to understand here when
it comes to this
is that comic book companies have what's
called a yearly summit well they all
basically go to
a particular place or they all meet up
and they say here's what we're going to
do for the next year right this is the
brand that we're going to relaunch in
the next year or this is the direction
we're going to be going in for the next
year and it usually just works that way
now sometimes it turns out to be a
multi-year effort right they sit down
and say okay like this is the big
plan that we have for the next five
years but these are the things we're
gonna do
this year to get us closer to that
five-year goal right so like if you look
at marvel comics and secret wars in 2015
that event was something like four or
five years in the making they were just
kind of going through year
after year and fleshing out what
direction stories were gonna go in to
get them to secret wars 2015.
uh and so with with this it was a
scenario where dc had basically sat down
and said okay
we're gonna reboot our landscape the
problem and and it's never really been
fully explained by dc
as to why they did this we just kind of
chalk it up to the idea that it was just
it was an initiative designed to just
make it easier to get into dc comics
but uh the idea was that dc ended up
meeting at a summit and then
essentially after the event of what was
called the flashpoint storyline where
the flash went back to save his mom's
life realized he created an
alternate reality and then went back to
let her die in order to set things back
to normal dc said
no we're going to use that to reboot
everything and that launched the new 52
in 2011. and so while while darkseid did
appear
in the first volume of the justice
league a lot of it was pretty ambiguous
as to why he was there the only real
indication we got
is that he was hunting for his daughter
and that was it right that's the only
real thing that we knew is that
darkseid's hunting for his daughter uh
that was something that would not really
become
something significant until much later
on down the line instead what you got
was dc sort of doing things in two
different ways
that dark side was presented to us the
way he kind of always had been
as this multiversal being right in the
sense that you have the entire
multiverse but there's only one dark
side out there the other part of this is
that we knew he had basically been
traveling from world to world and
seemingly conquering it that while that
was his main goal was to essentially
conquer universes across the multiverse
all in search of the anti-life equation
that what he'd also done is shown up to
earth as a secondary mission to find his
daughter
and so while the main justice league
story was going on you also saw dc
launch something called earth 2.
and historically speaking earth 2 was
the the universe of
golden age superheroes right so like the
flash jay garrick and the green lantern
alan scott some of those names you might
be familiar with
some of those names you may not but they
are basically superheroes from from
ages gone by the result of this is that
what we ended up having here was
steppenwolf showing up on earth 2
essentially as you know as he was
directed by darkseid and then basically
killing the justice league right he
literally killed them all in like the
first
issue well technically batman sacrificed
his life superman was turned into a pair
demon and then
i guess he technically killed wonder
woman by stabbing her to the back with a
sword
regardless all the the main superheroes
died in the first
issue and so the rest of earth 2 focused
on essentially a new generation of
superheroes in that universe
but for darkseid himself darkseid proper
his arrival here coincided with the
justice league actually meeting each
other for the very first time right
because at the time that the new 52 was
launched
superheroes had only been around for
about five years and so that's why if
you sit down and you were to read the
new 52
superman then that deals with superman
in the modern day right how you know how
he functions in the city of metropolis
and works the daily planet does all that
stuff but if you were to read
you know new 52 action comics that
focuses on the past stories and then
eventually they kind of
merge in the middle right they basically
you know action comics basically catches
up to
the main superman time period so the the
the present day and then they just kind
of go forward trading off stories
at that point in time and so the cool
thing about this is that with darkseid
showing up
batman superman uh wonder woman the
green lantern
uh you know hal jordan aquaman cyborg
all these guys had met for the very
first time and there was a little bit of
distrust there but the story was
exceedingly good the way it was done by
jeff johns ultimately it took the
combined efforts of the justice league
specifically using cyborg to
control a mother box and open a boom
tube to force darkseid back but he was
ultimately defeated but it was one heck
of a way to open the story right it was
just an amazing way
to to really initiate the launch of
justice league by having them face off
against darkseid and that was the
important thing is because as soon as he
was introduced by jeff
johns in the new 52 the first things
jeff johns established here was a dark
side was no slouch and even with all the
vaunted powers that the justice league
had
darkseid was a guy they couldn't take
out on their own they ultimately had to
force him back but they couldn't
actually kill him
because he was just too powerful for
them to handle right it was a last-ditch
effort it was a plan of batman to force
him back to his own universe
and then to force him back to his own
place and then kind of lock him away now
the cool thing about this is that
following that
dc about two years later launched
something that was called
villains month and villains month was a
genius idea by dc comics the whole idea
is they were going to take
existing titles and then introduce a one
shot
as part of that existing title to
basically tell the origins and stories
of villains right so with the justice
league for example as pertains to
darkseid you had justice league issue
number 23 then you had 23.1
and 23.1 was a one shot that gave us the
origin
of darkseid in the new 52 era now the
origin of dark side as it was given to
us here was actually a lot different
than the origin that we
that we'd previously seen in ages before
the events of the new 52 but the way
it's established here is a dark side it
was originally a guy named yuksas
and they lived on this desolate world
that really rough and it really sucked
but they it was essentially kind of
ruled by what we're called the old gods
and the idea behind this was that the
old gods were only really able to
sustain
and bolster their existence by feeding
essentially on the prayers of the people
that inhabited this world and that uk
sas was
really one of the first and really only
people who looked at the idea of the old
gods and said
why do we care about them right like you
know sure like they require our
sustenance in order to survive right
they feed on our prayers but they abuse
us they destroy our land
they they force us to live in this harsh
barren environment where there's never
really any rain
or anything like they don't make life
easy on us right they basically make
life as hard on us as they possibly can
why do we pray to these guys for a large
portion of society it was just because
it's always been that way there wasn't
really anybody kind of questioning
whether or not they should
it's that it's always this way right and
that's that that was a crazy thing
because it wasn't even just a matter of
the fact that like the the environment
was harsh like these old gods would
actually get into fights with each other
and when they did like they would start
tearing apart the land right so they
would destroy people's homes they would
ruin their crops all that kind of stuff
they really didn't care
anything about the people who were
keeping them alive and so in his
frustration and in his anger
ux basically concocted this plan to
destroy the old gods
right to essentially get rid of them and
then usurp their power right and so what
he ended up doing was sneaking
into the realm of the old gods when they
slept and then basically whispering in
their ear right whispering lies things
along those lines to convince them that
all the others were trying to destroy
them to effectively instigate civil war
among the old gods and when that
happened they basically ended up
eradicating themselves
and the crazy thing was that when you
had one of the old gods left and and he
really asked you know you sass like pray
to me right give me a prayer so that i
can survive
and then you know i will give you all
that you desire right like i will give
you everything you possibly want the
reality is that you sass
didn't care and so what he ends up doing
is going through and systematically
killing
every single one of the old gods and
then starts the process of
absorbing the power into himself and
then went forward as darkseid and so
what you had in addition to that were
some of the other old gods who'd
survived and then gave their power to
his brother and when they gave their
power to his brother he ultimately
became what we know as
high father now the problem with this
initial origin as it was told is that
while the two of these guys got into
conflict and
and while you had uk sas and then you
had iksaya who was who eventually became
high father while they waged against
each other and fought the truth was that
all we're told is that like after this
big battle that ultimately darkseid
created the apocalypse for himself as a
planet of torment and suffering
and that highfather created new genesis
as a place of enlightenment and peace
and they've just kind of been like that
ever since it wasn't really a complete
origin right it wasn't really a complete
story in terms of how we got from point
a to point b
and so what you end up getting is a few
follow-up issues right the first one
comes by way of what was called the
infinity man and the forever people and
this one was covered in issue number
five and what we end up learning is that
in the aftermath of this fight or at
least when this fight initially started
between uxas and anexia when they were
facing off against the old gods and
basically destroyed them that you ended
up having
yuga khan who also joined the fray and
yuga khan was the biological father of
darkseid right he was the guy who
literally sired this dude and so when
that happened because the power that
they had was so intense yuka khan
saw it as a uh an affront against the
old gods to destroy him and led a war
against his sons
ultimately he was destroyed as well or
not necessarily destroyed he was
actually locked away in the source wall
which for those of you guys who don't
know is basically this wall that
surrounds
every universe and then it also
surrounds the multiverse there's like
two iterations of the source wall more
or less
those individuals who try to leave the
multiverse and enter the source
if they're not of sufficient power or
their mind simply can't handle it they
end up getting trapped inside the source
wall and so that's what ended up
happening to yuga khan right he was
basically trapped inside the source wall
following his defeat and so this was
given to us
as a kind of immediate aftermath between
ixaya and uh and his brother
youth sacks basically killing the old
gods and then taking the power for
themselves
now following this you go into what's
called uh the godhead storyline and the
godhead storyline was a great story it
was part of the the jeff john's green
lantern run even though this particular
story was not actually written by jeff
johns in fact this story was
a a cumulative effort right it was
written by like van ginson and it was
written by robert vendetti and charles
soule
and colin bun it was written by like
four or five different people but there
was a lot of a lot of involvement here
but what we're basically told is that
in the aftermath of iksaya becoming high
father
and uh and uxas becoming darkseid that
they created their own respective realms
to kind of represent what they stood for
that darkseid believed in always and
continually hunting for the anti-life
equation
this equation that if a person were to
attain it and were to solve it would
allow them to dominate the wills
of all things seemingly across the
multiverse that there'd be nobody who
would be able to stand against them and
there's only really been one
instance in the history of dc comics
when we've seen darkseid successfully
attain the anti-life equation
and actually use it and that was during
the story final crisis which i'll have a
link to
down in the description that you're
welcome to check out it's it's it's a
little out there just for you guys who
are who are new to comics
it's a little out there just kind of go
into that expecting it right it's a
little wild
but uh hi father as kind of a being not
necessarily a perfect piece high
father's kind of a dick more often than
not
but as a being who stands as the
antithesis to dark side that new genesis
basically exists above the former realm
of the old gods to constantly remind
them of what happens
when a being attains such extreme power
and then goes awry
right and so his place is really more of
of what at least what passes for a place
of peace
i would say it's highly militaristic and
really more totalitarian
even if it is an enlightened
totalitarian government that's still
what it is right it's still a
dictatorship just one where he doesn't
force people to live in like you know
destitution and squalor like what
darkseid does and so dc basically
established as they had in years gone by
that dark side and high father are
constantly warring against each other
right like they're they're constantly
fighting amongst each other and so
because of the fact that it was
recognized that
if they were to really engage in like a
knock down drag out war
and they were to really start killing
each other in the most extreme way right
using the full totality of their power
then it would actually lead to the
destruction of the multiverse which is
something that was
presented in grant morrison's final
crisis which is again
a pretty crazy story but the important
thing here is that in order to keep this
from happening
what you had was a new god named metron
and metron was really more of a
chronicler if you're familiar with the
the notion of the watchers from marvel
comics that's basically what metron
is right he travels across the universe
and is in what's called his mobius chair
which will explain what that means here
in a little while and essentially just
observes
everything right and everything that he
observes gets chronicled in the mobius
chair it's like a chair that's a giant
library that stores everything that he
sees and so realizing what would happen
if the new gods went to war with each
other that it would destroy all
existence a piece was brokered between
the two
and so what you got was the son of high
father who was named scot-free who was
sent to live
on the planet apocalypse and then you
had the son of dark side named orion who
was sent to live on the the planet of
new genesis
and so because godfrey was the son of of
high father and because
neither wanted to see their sons die
that while scot-free was constantly
forced to live in like prisons and just
treated like crap he ended up becoming
mr miracle in the sense that he gained
the ability to basically
crack any lock anywhere in the
multiverse so no prison can ever really
hold him which might not sound that
great but it's actually awesome because
he's in effect a multiversal escape
artist so he always has a way out of any
situation and then you had
orion who normally would have become
like a terrible horrible person because
he lived on apocalypse ended up becoming
what was in effect
a new god hero right so following that
the peace being brokered
it basically allowed you know really
high father and his guys to always just
wait for the day
when darkseid would just say the heck
with it and just wage war against him
and it allowed darkseid to continue his
campaign
of always hunting for the anti-life
equation now wrapping back around to
earth 2 this kind of became what was
considered to be the secret obsession of
darkseid in dc comics in the sense that
with the idea of darkseid having lost to
the hero is what was called
earth prime or earth zero in the dc
landscape which is basically the main dc
comics universe the dark side began the
process of bolstering his forces for the
purpose of returning to earth zero
somewhere along the line but with earth
having been defeated and really taken
over by steppenwolf in the name of
darkseid
the dark side in turn after having
suffered a massive defeat against what
were called the daxomites who were
basically kryptonians that had broken
off and then just
you know took up residence on a
different planet somewhere else uh that
he ended up going into the heart of
apocalypse itself and basically
consuming the heart of the planet in
order to heal himself
is essentially what happened what this
meant was that while the traditional
planet of apocalypse would end up being
destroyed the idea was to effectively
take over earth 2 wipe out all life that
was there and then turn that into a new
apocalypse now the reason why people
view and really state
that the new 52 earth 2 storyline was so
great was quite literally because of
this story right because of the really
the new generation of heroes
trying to fend the earth off against
darkseid and then ultimately being
unsuccessful right it's a story where
the heroes essentially lost
and it was awesome the the way that it
went down but what this did is it
allowed darkseid to continue kind of
bolstering his forces and then going
forward with the intention of launching
an attack against against the main dc
universe again now
something else that i want to point out
here between the time that apocalypse
was originally formed and going to his
first appearance
in justice league right when he faced
off against the main justice league team
there are things that took place but
we're not really given a chronological
timeline
as to when they happened all we know is
just that somewhere along the line
they took place the formation of the
furies for example is when that took
place so if you guys when you guys were
watching snyder's run towards the end of
the movie and you saw that that older
woman right that woman off to the side
they don't really reference her and you
wouldn't know it unless you knew who she
was
by all standards of measurement that
looks like grainy goodness and granny
goodness is basically the de facto
leader of the female furies now there
are male furies but imagine if wonder
woman was a bad guy and she worked for
darkseid and there was a team of her
that's basically what the female
theories are one of those is actually a
woman named barda who basically took uh
you know ended up going against the
female furies and then basically became
like a superhero who ended up marrying
scot-free right man ended up marrying uh
the son of high father who was on
who was on uh apocalypse right so one of
the other things that darkseid had done
is he had basically managed to capture
what was called an aspect of the black
racer and the black racer is basically
the representation of death
as it appears to the new gods but with
darkseid capturing it and then basically
being able to control it the only way to
really force the black racer to bend the
dark side's will was if it was bonded to
a living hoax and that'll become
something important here in a little bit
once we talk about dark side war but the
cool thing about this is that following
this
you saw a few little moments with
darkseid things like uh
like convergence where he appeared there
his power was bolstered and it was
increased beyond what we
traditionally sought when we initially
saw him appear in the justice league
story um you ended up seeing things like
divergence which actually introduced his
daughter grail and kind of established
that she
is the really the daughter of darkseid
and then an amazonian woman from an
alternate reality so you saw these these
really cool introductions that existed
there but it was all done towards the
purpose
or at least believed to have been done
towards the purpose of bolstering and
going towards this definitive concept
the problem with this was that the
longer the new 52 went on
the more the continuity errors became
apparent and the more the lack of
planning became obvious and so the
result was that for
new fans the new 52 was an awesome
concept at first
that became more confusing and even a
little lackluster as time went on for
existing fans depending on who you
talked to they were just
wholly pissed off that it even happened
in the first place because all the
continuity that they had been raised
with when they had been reading comics
ever since they were younger was
effectively just wiped away right just
in the blink of an eye and so what you
saw dc doing was trying to rework this
with something called dcu
where there wasn't really any continuity
in their storytelling it was just
telling stories for the sake of
storytelling but nobody really liked it
because people like to know that things
happen in a particular order which is
especially important if you're somebody
who's getting into comics and you're
trying to make sense of it right because
we as people just naturally enjoy order
and structure we like to know
a leads to b leads to c all the way down
to z and so in the aftermath of what was
considered to be
a lackluster response to the new 52
combined with an even worse response to
stories like convergence and dcu that dc
led up to the story
rebirth and rebirth was basically just
wiping all that stuff away
and in effect in the eyes of jeff johns
and the people who spearheaded the event
doing what dc should have done in the
first place which was keep everything
that worked from before the new 52
and then blended with what the new 52
ended up being right with the new
concepts and teams and
the changes that people actually enjoyed
and so in an effort to go into the new
they basically needed a story to kind of
catapult all this and so what we ended
up getting was the dark side war event
and the dark side war event brought in
two characters that we
were really one that we were familiar
with but have been changed and the other
we knew
virtually nothing about right the first
one was grail the daughter of darkseid
the second one was the anti-monitor and
to kind of break away from this for a
second
the anti-monitor is is a lot of you guys
have probably heard of even if you don't
really know
the ins and outs of his character and it
has been changed more recently in years
the anti-monitor was
was basically this this guy who was
responsible for wiping out the
multiverse during the events of crisis
on infinite earth now ultimately he was
brought back during things like sinestro
core war things along those lines but
the important takeaway from all this is
that he was totally changed up during
the events of dark side war now i've got
this story down in the description so we
won't go super in depth here but the
idea behind dark side war was
in effect that before he became the
anti-monitor that guy was a person named
mobius and he was curious about you know
the nature of the universe and its
origin and all that kind of stuff but he
had come from a place called the
anti-matter universe and so in his
experiments and because of his curiosity
he unwittingly unleashed something
called the anti-life equation and the
anti-life equation as we stated
previously is basically this
mathematical proof that if you're able
to master it you can dominate the wills
of everybody in existence basically take
away
their own free will and they become
servants to you they become slaves to
you just whatever it is that you want
them to do
and so with with that coming into
existence mobius had kind of been
tainted by this right and he was
ultimately transformed into the
anti-monitor now the whole idea behind
that was completely changed
by scott snyder during his run on
justice league
specifically going into what was called
death metal uh so again you know that
you kind of
see that for what it was at the time but
that's not the exact standard that we
operate now
the important thing behind all this is
that the anti-monitor believed that if
he were to kill darkseid it would free
him from this
kind of taint that he has on himself and
so that's what led to the instigation of
the of the dark side war
and so ultimately what you ended up
having was dark side and anti-monitor
going to war against each other
fighting each other and then ultimately
darkseid was killed right
darkseid was basically destroyed and
that was the end of his character now
what we ended up finding out later on
is that grail had actually resurrected
darkseid more or less you know
brought him back to life that he was
initially kind of reborn as a baby
aged up by grail to face off against the
justice league a second time
and then ultimately he was defeated and
then reverted back into a baby again the
big problem with all this is that
everybody and really the way that dc was
building it
grail was going to be like this next
huge villain that was on par with
darkseid she wasn't right like she was a
character that appeared for a story and
then dc just never did anything with her
after that right she had like a little
bit of an introduction when it spun off
into justice league odyssey but that was
basically it the important thing behind
all this is that following
really the the end of dark side war and
going into the events of what was in
effect
dc rebirth that darkseid was effectively
reborn now the funny thing about this
is that darkseid did return in the pages
of wonder woman but not initially
initially when wonder woman rebirth was
launched it was this ridiculously
amazing story
by greg rucka it's it's it's probably
one of the best wonder woman stories
ever told if you've never had a chance
to read it i highly suggest you pick it
up but the whole idea behind that was to
basically establish the notion that
wonder woman had never actually returned
to themschira even though we'd seen her
show up to themselves that it never
actually happened now as to the reason
for that i will not spoil here you
should go buy it and read it on your own
the revelation
is just mind-blowing it's it's cool but
the long and short of this
is that darkseid is basically taken by
grail they travel around
to these various gods that exist across
the dc universe and kill them right so
one of the first to fall is hercules
which basically transforms dark side
into a teenager and then following that
is zeus who basically transformed
darkseid into his current form now after
that grail is ultimately defeated and
essentially just removed from the dc
landscape
and this goes directly into dan admits
justice league odyssey now with
with darkseid existing in the justice
league odyssey event this was coinciding
with what scott snyder was doing with
regards to his justice league run the
idea of the totality the return of
perpetua who had created the existing
multiverse intended to basically wipe it
all clean and then recreate it in her
own image while dc will not necessarily
point to the events of snyder's justice
league and death metal event as being a
reboot by all standards of measurement
it was but as for darkseid his whole
goal in justice league odyssey
over the course of the run was basically
this revelation that he intended to
sidestep perpetua that what he intended
to do was to amass enough power
to one wipe her from existence and then
two recreate the multiverse in his own
image now ultimately
the downside to this of course is that
it never came to fruition right darkseid
was never able to achieve his goal but
more so than that justice league odyssey
was ultimately cancelled due to
what were in effect lackluster sales the
longer the series went on the truth
about it is that it's a sad state of
affairs because justice league odyssey
was amazing i did the first video
here and then the more i read it the
more i was like i'm just gonna do this
for me like i'm just gonna read it for
myself
i'm just not gonna make videos on it
because i like it and i just i want to
keep things for myself
and so ultimately darkseid just kind of
vanished from the dc landscape yet again
uh and that really goes into
what's happening right now in dc comics
which is called the new frontier
and this basically brings into really
brings into play
the notion of true form dark side and
true form dark side was a
really a fan concept that was created uh
following
or really during the depiction of
darkseid by grant morrison and it was a
way to kind of reconcile and answer the
question
if darkseid had died previously or been
killed previously then why wasn't his
death or why didn't his death have the
same consequence that it did
during final crisis when his death
basically led to the destruction of the
multiverse and fans basically
rationalized or or
kind of created the logic and saying
that well those versions of dark side
that we saw were simply just avatars
right they were facsimiles of the true
form dark side and that when
true form dark side was killed that's
what happened during final crisis
and that's why the multiverse was
starting to collapse because true form
dark side was just
that powerful that when he died the
multiverse essentially started to go
with him right and so
uh with true form darkside showing up
during infinite frontier number one
we don't know what the play of his
character is gonna be like he literally
just showed back up maybe three weeks
ago right so we don't know what his what
is full on plan is going to be
presumably it'll be something nefarious
and the pursuit of the anti-life
equation right i mean the guy is
obnoxiously powerful
uh but we don't really know what is what
his grand scheme is going to be so with
that being said guys hopefully this gets
you guys caught up makes you guys an
expert on at least the newest iteration
of darkseid as he exists right now but
if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you